my name is Logan prao I'm a data
engineer at the legal services
corporation uh where I work on a
relatively new project called the Civil
Court data
initiative so just to sort of start out
and and Center this talk a little bit on
the issues that I'm going to be be
discussing for the next 15 to 20 minutes
um let's just start with you know what
is the Civil Justice System
um civil court is somewhat uh different
from Criminal Court which I'm not sure
but I would imagine a lot of you all in
this room are probably much more
familiar with that's going to be the
things where you know you commit a crime
like uh you know robbery or something
like that you're often uh arrested by a
police officer um you go to court you
plead guilty or not guilty uh you're
handed a verdict and then you go to jail
um civil court is a different side of
that right so civil court is going to be
the things that you're going to appear
in court for um but where you didn't
necessarily commit a crime so this is
going to be things like eviction which
is going to be the focus of what I'm
talking about today um but also things
like debt collection uh
guardianship um you know cases like that
right
um these areas are slightly different
but in a lot of ways they can be equally
as harrowing um so for eviction for
example
um what happens in these cases can uh
uproot a fundamental human right for a
lot of individuals their right to
shelter their right to a home um it can
leave folks with uh forcing them to to
to leave their sense of community their
sense of belonging um a lot of their
possessions are often Left Behind um
into sort of a world of uncertainty um
where you don't necessarily know where
you're going to be sleeping next or um
where you're going to be just at home
next um the organization that I work for
Legal Services Corporation was stood up
in the
1970s uh because uh with with the
explicit purpose um to provide uh legal
assistance to
um individuals that are navigating this
system because a key difference between
criminal and civil court uh is that
folks aren't guaranteed the right to a
lawyer so that classic image that you
all might have for something like Law
and Order where a person's Miranda
rights are being read and they're being
told that if you can't afford a lawyer
one will be appointed to you that
doesn't happen in Civil Court that's
individuals are often left to navigate
an incredibly complex legal process
entirely unassisted uh and so our goal
is to essentially provide funding to
Legal Aid organizations across the
country uh that work to represent these
individuals um who qualify
uh in court now the project that I work
on within Legal Services Corporation uh
what is known as a civil court data
initiative um and we essentially believe
that Court data when standardized um and
analyzed in aggregate uh can be an
incredibly powerful Tool uh in helping
to allocate limited resources uh and
finite time for these legal
organizations working on the ground so
you can see here is our our current map
of coverage um this was taken for our
from our website which you can find uh
the URL up in the in the corner there um
and the first thing you may notice is
that there's a lot of white on the
screen that's because we don't have all
of the data yet um we have a lot of
states for which we just don't know what
the eviction landscape looks like um to
put that in context imagine if we just
couldn't say how many people died of
heart disease every year imagine IM what
you what that would mean for policy and
just general decisions from you know in
the medical field um all of that um
that's what the eviction landscape
certainly looked like in 2019 when this
map was completely white um and in a lot
of ways what it still looks like today
um our goal uh is to be able to answer
questions like you know or to be able to
say things like you know how many folks
how many individuals in Virginia um are
facing eviction um of all renters and
the answer might surprise you um there
were relative to the number of renter
households in the state of V Virginia
there were about 12% of those were
facing eviction filings um these numbers
are High um and that's sort of what
we're trying to present with uh
collecting this
data to get technical for a second um
and not too technical um we have our
data pipeline um essentially looks like
this and this is this is pretty
simplified but but this is the basic
idea we have a data source uh which for
us can be Court websites bulk data
downloads um you know there are only
three up here uh but to put it into
context there are over 1,200 different
unique jurisdictions across the entire
country uh and we're working to
basically collect all of that data um
and aggregate it into um a standardized
system we use a variety of sort of
cutting Ed
data orchestration platforms like DBT
and prefa and AWS Services the list goes
on and it would make me sound sound
smarter than I am to just sort of re say
them out loud but the end goal is to
kind of just have a a set of
standardized data data sets that we can
put in a data Lake um and this is you
know overall relatively relatively
simple the idea is to basically just
have queriable data that our team
research analysts and other folks can
use um it can be incredibly complicated
to do that
standardization um but the end goal is
to essentially just have databases that
are accessible to folks um and what our
data pipeline looked like for a while
was that we were basically just
subsetting that data and providing it to
the end user the legal aid
organizations this pretty much
exclusively when we were first starting
out uh took the form of just
spreadsheets um really boring stuff um
to be completely honest I mean I know
that a lot of folks in this room are
familiar with you know uh R and and
other you know data science tools you
might look like look at a data uh data
set like this and say there's a lot that
I can do with that it's standardized
it's in a long format you know Port it
into R and you could have some
visualizations going um you know there's
there's a lot of fun stuff that you can
do with that
but remember the the folks that were not
that we're trying to get this data to
aren't data scientists they're lawyers
um they don't come from that computer
science or data science or even just any
sort of coding um background they
they've spent their lives in courts um
studying legal text uh in the same way
that if you were to ask me you know can
you tell me what like can you just read
this legal e and interpret it and I
would you know look at with wide
eyes the same thing kind of happens um
you know if if you give someone uh with
a legal background a spreadsheet and
basically say you know answer whatever
question you have um but that's kind of
what we wanted to do is we wanted to be
able to provide folks with the tools to
answer questions that they had we didn't
really want to answer questions for them
um we just wanted to or or tell them
rather tell them what questions they had
um and and provide the answers we wanted
these the these these folks to be able
to basically you know answer questions
that were specific to their context um a
story that I uh like to tell with this
um or I I don't really like to tell but
I think it's um a good example here uh
is that when we were using this method
of basically just sending off data sets
uh to different legal aid
organizations uh we had for a particular
grantee a particular legal aid
organization that we were working with
we had sent them uh a data set and we
uploaded it to box uh just as a it was
our file sharing platform um and we you
know emailed it sent it off uh didn't
really hear back for about two weeks and
then in a team meeting we were you know
just internally talking about it and we
circled back um we thought you know
whatever happened with that did they use
it uh and so we went back and we looked
at that box link and we realized that we
hadn't actually shared shared it
externally we had uploaded it to box but
it was only shared within our
organization uh and so nobody could
actually see it outside of of us and the
people that the folks we were sharing it
with never reached out to us they never
asked us you know they never said hey
you know we we clicked on the link and
we can't actually access it um and I
think that you know what better way to
show that like the data that you're
sending off isn't being used or isn't
important um than just the fact that
like they can't they didn't even try
access it or they didn't or maybe they
tried to access it and then when they
couldn't they didn't care enough to to
actually follow up um so that was a real
eye opening moment for us um when we
kind of realized you know this data
isn't actually being used we're we're
we're we have this really complex
pipeline going from Court website all
the way to standardized data sets it's
getting 95% of the way there but then we
we just weren't going the last 5% and we
weren't saying you know what is that
that is actually going to help us to
meet these legal aid organizations where
they are and get them the data that they
need um and that's when we sort of
revised and uh this was a little bit
before the quarto phase so I know that
this is um a little bit or craze so this
is a little bit um out of date but we we
used our markdown to essentially
generate uh weekly reports um that took
the same data from the spreadsheets that
I was showing you on the last page um
and just put it into a really easily
read easily digestable format uh that
answered surface level questions in our
eyes um sort of the lowest common
denominator of questions that you could
answer um across all of our court data
um and we provided that to to our end
users to the legal a organizations um
you can see here are just a couple of
examples um you know for Vermont uh you
can see you know we it it it has a
little bit I'm not sure if you can read
that text but essentially what it says
up there at the top is just you know a
brief introduction we collect data
across 14 counties in Vermont um and
this is this this graph generated in
ggplot just sort of shows you know that
that's what the the landscape kind of
looks like across the board that's what
eviction filings look like um over the
past year similarly you have an outline
for Connecticut there that basically
just shows it's a heat map that just
shows eviction filing hotpots so areas
in darker red uh are going to be areas
that that have the most eviction filings
or more eviction filings um than than uh
the areas in a lighter color red
um so yeah so I kind of alluded to this
before but uh the questions that we were
answering were were pretty basic or
trying to answer with these memos that
were only you know two pages in length
um and didn't really have a lot of text
um it was just you know what do eviction
filing Trends look like over the over
the past year in a particular state or
you know what counties have the most
eviction filings and um as well you know
how does representation differ between
landlords and tenants uh in these cases
the answer might surprise you it's wide
there is a huge disparity between
representation for tenants and landlords
um and really just you know in answering
the or in creating these memos I just
want to hammer the point home that we
weren't trying to answer every every
question that they might have um instead
which which is something that we were
doing with with our prev data sets
instead we were just providing a taste
of what we had with the data and
welcoming them to come back to us the
the the organizations to come back to us
uh and ask us questions um and and say
things like I had no or I had some idea
um that my County had the highest rate
of eviction filings uh in the entire
state but this confirms it uh and I'd
really like to you know uh know who the
top filers are who the who the top top
companies are that are evicting folks in
my state or uh what is the what are the
judgments what are the outcomes of these
these cases uh and what what does that
look like
um and so it took us from this data
pipeline um
to a slightly revised version where we
still had the data source and the data
Lake but rather than going from
standardized data sets directly to the
end user um essentially what we were
doing was just going by way of you know
data memos for our markdown and passing
that along um again this diagram is a
little bit overs simplistic in a way
because I think that it it implies that
we stopped sending data um or or spread
sheets um which isn't true we had data
memos but we really used those as just
sort of a jumping off point as a way to
to get the ball rolling to get the
conversation going around sharing data
um and what ended up happening is like I
said folks came back to us and asked us
you know can I have this data um and
then the spreadsheets that we were
sending them were things that they that
were actually important things that they
actually wanted um which is obviously
always key when you're sending off data
um we found that you know we went from
uh sending off data that nobody had
asked for and nobody was looking at to
folks actually like not being able to
send data off fast enough we had to grow
our team because we couldn't respond to
all of the specific data requests that
we were getting which is always a great
thing to
do and so some of the outcomes from this
work um there were a couple of different
things um principally we had improved
data accessibility and understanding so
again uh folks were no longer having to
uh you know work in Excel to find an
answer to their specific question um
they could just have that analysis done
for
them this also improved access via just
sharing the information um
directly beyond that we had time
efficiency and this is both time
efficiency on our end uh because we
weren't coming up with custom data sets
to send off an anticipation of a
specific legal aid organization's needs
um instead we were zooming out to the
state level um and automatically
generating these reports um you know we
put them on
uh for those of you familiar with Amazon
web services we put them on an ec2
instance uh in Amazon web services and
kind of just let it run in the cloud and
it does that every day or excuse me
every week um so every Monday uh I log
on to my computer and uh just sort of
double check the output of the uh the
word documents and make sure that you
know everything looks good we also have
more efficient tests that are running
programmatically but um as a final check
that's that's really what I do uh every
every Monday is just over my cup of
coffee I I look at each individual
document and I make sure that it's
looking good and that's the extent of it
and then we can just sort of let them
live there and share them um and you
know revisit things on a on a quarterly
basis um rather than having to
regenerate new documents every week or
for every individual occasion um on the
part of the legal aid organizations
again not having to do uh the analysis
with our data um uh that that that's a
huge
timesaver and then the last thing is
just increased conversation which is
really what our end goal is is to be
able to talk to folks uh and you know
get their Insight of of how the data can
best help them um and that's definitely
a downstream uh of this so as a recap um
you know aggregating cleaning
standardizing this data um was really
sort of the first step in the process
but we thought that it was the whole
process we thought that just if we were
going to be able to uh collect all of
this disaggregate information uh and you
know like people would naturally be
interested in it um and that was
something that we learned just isn't the
case um instead we had to to to take a
less is more approach um to answering
more just superficial questions
initially um but seeing that you know
that would lead to increased
conversation and more data sharing down
the
road um and in the end this this really
improved engagement and understanding of
the data so thank you very much um I'll
say that if you're interested in viewing
the memos that I've been talking about
uh there is a QR code there that you can
sort of scan that but yeah happy to
answer any questions thank
you thank you so much Logan we have time
for uh at least one question
so what are you planned or aspirational
next steps for data sharing with your
stakeholders yeah so that's an excellent
question um so I think that the big
thing right is uh creating interactive
um visualizations in sort of like a
dashboard format um so we have our
website which uh you can see at the URL
there then we have these static memos um
but the website is more of a public
facing um you know that is very both of
these are very public facing which um
can limit uh the amount of data that we
really want to publish on it because we
don't want to just give out all of the
data for security privacy concerns um
and so the end goal would be to create
uh a dashboard that allows um specific
folks like these grante we call them
grantees because uh we do fund them um
that's the main work that LSC does um is
uh to assign
provide them with information that way
sort of more privately thank you
[Applause]
again